you know what most people forgot that
was happening pre-pandemic think about
it
february of 2020 the economy we had
128-month economic expansion
that's 128 months of economic expansion
in america
everybody was making money everything
was great people putting money in the
market making millions everybody
felt great then the pandemic hit you
know what the pandemic did
it exposed bad leadership today we're
going to talk about how bad leaders were
exposed during the pandemic
[Music]
so look as leaders you're going to go
through bad times but what made the
pandemic more challenging than others
is the fact that it lasted a long time
you know you'll have a problem it'll
last a month a week
a day few hours but not
six months over and over and
over and this pressure of things we've
never experienced before people like oh
my
gosh i don't know how to handle this
stuff and so that lasting pressure
exposed bad leaders more than ever
before because they were typically
able to handle pressure for an hour a
day or a week or
maybe even a month but definitely not
six months that was one of the things
that the pandemic did the next one is it
showed us
which leaders were for the people and
which leaders
were for themselves this doesn't matter
if it's politics
or business you knew which leaders in
politics were all about themselves
and which leaders in business were all
about themselves you you kind of saw the
fact that some of these leaders were for
the people
you may be working at a place and in
your office you could say let me tell
you i learned
the people i work with on a daily basis
they were for me i had no idea they were
going to be okay with this
that we had never done a remote
leadership type of a model before
and they were able to get people to the
way they had i just really liked the way
they handled it
with the people but during the pandemic
everybody learned
if it was about the people or if it was
about the boss
everyone learned about that during the
pandemic next
it created a filtering process and what
i mean by filtering process is
you learned who is a peacetime leader
and a wartime leader it's a purely a
filtering process
you never know who's tough until
pressure comes in sports you don't know
who can handle pressure
until there's two seconds left on the
shot clock and you hand the ball to a
guy
and anthony davis hits the shot with two
seconds left and he wins
and a paul george couldn't you don't
know the difference between how pressure
is handled
it's very easily talked about but you
learn about it
during pressure times it created a very
simple filtering process to identify the
wartime leaders
versus peacetime leaders during the
pandemic it's very good to look good
when everything is good
it's very good to look good when the
economy expands for 128 months
it's very hard to look good when we have
a pandemic for six months
another thing the pandemic did is it
revealed the true character of the
leader and what i mean by the true
character of the leader is very simple
look you know i've worked in the
financial industry now nearly 20 years i
got in it in 01 so 19 years right
when 07 i'll never forget november of 07
i was in california and mortgage
companies started
shutting down and and you saw certain
people that
were doing business the right way they
were not doing business the right but it
revealed a lot about their character in
0.708 and it was a rough time man i mean
it was not a good time when the market
hit during 0708 you know you had all
these repos taking place in san
bernardino valley
it was not a good time but character was
revealed during
those times the same thing happened
during
the pandemic we can we're very good at
hiding ourselves
we're very good at acting most of us
would make
pretty decent hollywood actors because
we act in life right
as if either everything is good or as if
we are doing a great job and then
boom something hits and you realize man
i don't know if i was as tough as i
thought i was
i didn't know if i could handle as much
pressure as i could i i thought i could
but the pandemic definitely revealed
that here's the other thing during the
pandemic
is everybody's put under the microscope
why here's why look
no one likes being put under the
microscope why because with the
microscope comes what
nitpicking watch this watch that watch
this
and it's a lot of judgment who the hell
wants to be put under a microscope
you ever looked at your skin under a
microscope your skin may look good on
camera and then go look at it on the
microscope like
oh my gosh my skin is terrible under the
microscope right
because no one likes that kind of
judgment look ellen degeneres just came
out this morning with her talk about
what kind of a summer she said so i've
had a great summer obviously being
sarcastic
everybody's saying oh toxic environment
toxic iron toxic environment
how come no one talked about this while
she was crushing it and there was no
pandemic
why are they all of us on targeting her
during
the worst time in america in the last
couple decades
minus 9 11 right how come no one said
anything the last 17 years
well because it's bad times and bad
times more people have more times
people have more time to look at you
under the microscope
and unfortunately this is not even about
good leadership and bad leadership
if you choose to be a leader and make
boss type decisions
eventually the microscope's going to
show up and you either have to be able
to handle it and say look
yes my standard's never been perfection
my standard's been progress
or if you act like you're perfect
forever
you're eventually going to be under so
much scrutiny and pressure
that you're going to have a lot of
mental and emotional breakdowns behind
closed doors that nobody knows about
if you pitch yourself as this perfect
savior that everyone's been waiting for
uh you'll pay price for it emotionally
and it'll be private it will not be
public
and then eventually you may get to a
point that you're going to want to be
private and hide for the rest of your
life and you don't want that
another one is it showed a different
leadership style meaning
you saw people that were wanting to go
out there and talk about it for example
trump wanted to go out and talk and take
every interview
he talked about it biden you didn't
really see biden being out there talking
to people
cuomo wanted to go out there and talk
about it newsom wasn't as public as
cuomo was
cuomo every day you woke up there was a
new york hearing that he was doing to
talk about the problems that they had
the night before
and it got bigger and bigger and bigger
and people kind of learned about cuomo
most people didn't know about cuomo they
knew about him in new york maybe in a
couple different places with the story
of his
brother and his father but they didn't
know how to handle pressure
but you got a chance to see you know
there was a little bit of levity
with his approach under pressure you
know
there was a little bit of royalty with
newsome under pressure
there was a little bit of wartime with
trump under pressure
there was a little bit of hiding with
biden under pressure
you kind of just saw everybody on how
they were handling
things under pressure and you saw the
leadership style that you liked or
didn't like and that was on you where
you said
you know this wasn't my policy by the
way but i liked the way cuomo was
handling things with pressure i i liked
it a lot you know
i became a fan i became a fan of the
fact that he's sitting there
coming out there and talking and people
are sitting asking him questions and
some of the questions was pressure
questions and
he didn't like him but he did to his
best of his abilities to answer it
but somehow someway the populist felt
comfortable about the fact that
he was being transparent at least look
when you're being asked hundreds of
questions every day
you're not going to nail every single
one of them but at least the people know
that you have the audacity to get in
front of camera
live this is not let's pre-record and
cut it properly
live to address these issues we learn
about everybody on how to handle it at
your company
you'll learn how to handle it did they
email you did they only email
communication
did they do a live or did they do prep
videos
did they just sit there on a camera with
you on a zoom or a facetime and say
you know with their hundreds of leaders
and say what's on your mind
what's concerning you you had the
ability to make a decision on how they
handle those issues
if your company did it right and you won
well listen you better plot those guys
at the top that did it right
if your company didn't then you also
paid a price for it again this is when
you realize what's good leadership and
what's bad leadership
next handling of money and resources why
is this so important here's why
if 128 months you experience economic
expansion
shouldn't you by the end of 128 months
have more cash than you had to pre-128
months
meaning if during the 128 months market
goes
up and up and up and up and up
you probably should have more capital
you probably should have more money
you probably should have more cash how
does this benefit you when a crisis
takes place
you don't have to do 60 layoffs when the
crisis takes place
you don't have to stop everything that
you're doing on a daily basis when a
crisis takes place
you don't come from a place of fear when
a crisis takes place
you don't come from a place of anxiety
because you don't have enough money to
pay everybody's salary
you're able to make more poised
decisions
this is why you saw a lot of companies
who were sitting around
saying oh my gosh we don't have as much
capital as we thought we had
we everybody learned about the travel
business
everybody learned about which companies
had no money saved
everybody learned which retailers were
not ready for this
everybody learned how money is being
handled
behind closed doors and those who handle
the right boom
they became wealthier those who didn't
handle the right boom
they went out of business like this
because there was no capital
during the economic expansion that took
place here's the other one that took
place
it created a need for off the cuff
you kind of saw off the cuff decision
making process versus research base what
do i mean by this
so somebody can come in and they're like
well you know we have a pandemic taking
place ah
it's not a big deal it's gonna be fine
this is just a bunch of this it's gonna
go away okay great
maybe but what if it's not are you doing
any research
because you don't know how people are
gonna react let's just say you're right
and that's how you react but in an
economy
it's not about how you react it's about
how the economy is going to react
it's about how the people are going to
react if the people who are your
customers
react in a certain way and you don't do
research on the way they're going to
react you're going to pay price versus i
don't know if i'm making sense or not
let me say this one more time so
some people are like what's going to be
fine it's not a big deal it's going to
be totally fine
you may be right but if you react that
way because you're
calm the other 95 or your customers
don't
and you don't think about their concerns
you're gonna lose them
because you have to think about how
they're going to react not how you're
going to react
yes you being common composed helps them
but
you still have to understand how the
reaction will be which means what
the next time something like this
happens say the next crisis happens is a
war
say we have an attack say we have a
espionage situation say we have a
bio warfare say we have a cyber attack
that happens to america
say anything happens that's never
happened to you before how are you going
to handle it with the way people are
going to respond to it
and how much research you're going to do
you got to come back and do a lot of
research so it's not just off the cuff
without you having a proper research
i've been on both sides i made off the
comments that i wasn't prepared and i
paid a price for it and i realized it's
better off me going out there doing a
little bit of research
every time i have done more research
about a topic i've made better decisions
every time it's been off the cuff
without a lot of research i paid a price
for it
so the recommendation is spend some time
adding the research the next time crisis
takes place
let's continue it also showed how many
leaders seek counsel
and how many didn't meaning how many
leaders went to
a a a group of people who have been
through this before to say how should we
handle this situation here
i've never been through this before what
do you think look i i i run an insurance
company myself we have now around 17 000
agents
and when that took place one of the ceos
i respect the most
called me i respect him he's my mentor
he called me
and he says so what do you think about
the handling right now what are you guys
doing about this
what are you guys doing about that how
are you guys handling this how are you
guys handling that
you know what i made me think about
here's a guy that runs a 40 billion
dollar company he's calling me
so i'm sitting there saying who are you
calling right and i have my list of
people that i was calling to get advice
but him and i always go back and forth
so you sit there and you realize man
if this guy that's running a 40 billion
dollar company how about the rest
and we had a great hour and a half
conversation together
he said how are you guys doing this i
said we're doing this what are you guys
doing about this we're doing this
well we don't know what to do about this
how are you guys doing this we're doing
this okay that's good we're going to do
that by the way
we're doing this if you want to take up
think about doing this oh that's a great
idea we'll do this
what happened by the time of that
collaboration with other people that are
also going through the same issue
you came up with better ideas on how to
handle it within
your own company another thing that gets
exposed during the pandemic was a lack
of empathy what do i mean by lack of
empathy
look a lot happened you know some can be
fake some can be real some can be
some can be you know you know maybe even
exaggerated but regardless you'll learn
whose approach was filled with empathy
you learned whose approach was
understanding you learned whose approach
was
i understand that this is something
that's concerning you i totally get it
you know here's how i see it but i
totally understand where you're coming
from
empathy has a tendency of creating a
retention model
in your company and you learn very
quickly who
is someone that leads with empathy and
who doesn't
last point i'll make use the following
the pandemic also force you to take a
stand
a lot of people don't want to take a
stand because if you take a stand you
may not like
certain people may not like you when you
take a stand you may have a group of
people that may be against you
but it force you to take a stand leaders
have to take a stand during the pandemic
you couldn't just go out there and be
vanilla if you were vanilla you probably
lost people if you were vanilla you
probably lost clients
you had to take a stand people had to
kind of see your position what did they
agree or not people respect the fact
that you took a stand
here's where i'm at guys based on the
information i have i believe dot dot dot
dot dot
and those who took a stand they came out
of it good look
all of these things we're talking about
i can set the stuff out and not add
another 20 points to it
the whole moral of the story about this
video is leadership is tough
leadership is not easy leadership is
emotional leadership is not about
perfection
leadership is about progress leadership
is about you saying i'm going to get
better i'm going to do my best
i'm going to make some mistakes but i'm
not going to try to win 100 of people
because you're not
a leader that tries to 100 of people
they typically don't have any real loyal
followers
because you're not going to have any of
that stuff but also leader who
is not willing to do their best to lead
every kinds of people is also not the
best kind of people meaning
if you only know how to lead people that
like you you're not a leader
if you only know how to lead people who
think you're awesome
then you're not a great leader if you
only know how to lead people who agree
with you
then you're not a great leader then
you've got some work to do as a leader
because
you know when i was running a small
organization in a small sales office
with five people it was very easy
everybody liked me
when i went to 50 there were some people
that didn't like me and i liked that
but i had to learn but the moment i
couldn't handle it my organization
shrunk
i'm like wait a minute why are you
trying to get everybody like you then we
went to 100 people
then 500 people then a thousand people
and a lot of people were like oh my gosh
i don't agree with your style on how
you're doing this i totally understand
but i'm going to try to accommodate
everybody in the company but i'm going
to stick to my style and what i take a
stand on this is
what i'm all about so leadership's got a
lot of benefits but it's also got some
stuff this is why many people don't want
to take leadership positions
this is why many people say i don't want
that kind of responsibility
i was always curious and when i go to
certain people and i said i want to
promote you to a manager
you know how many people in my career
when i went to them to say i want to
promote you the manager they said i
don't want to
i said what do you mean just i don't
want to be a manager why don't you want
to be a manager
just let me do my job why not because
i just don't want to be judged if i make
the wrong call as a lead i'm like
you got to be kidding me but guess what
that's okay
not everybody wants that not everybody
wants to be a shot caller
and be judged for the bad shots that you
called not everybody wants that
but this damn pandemic let me tell you
this pandemic definitely exposed
uh and revealed a lot about all of us
you and i
all of us during the pandemic and uh my
hope is
uh that during this pandemic we all came
out better stronger in a way
where you're able to look at some of the
bad mistakes you made to get better
so the next time a crisis happens we
know how to handle it because
bad times are coming again just so you
know that we're going to have some good
times but i guarantee you there's more
bad times
and hopefully this made you a better
leader so you know how to handle next
time when this thing comes around
better and better and better and again
if you're watching this and you're
asking yourself i want to find a way to
become a better leader
i did a video a few months ago due to
the pandemic titled wartime leadership
versus peacetime leadership if you've
not watched it click over here to watch
that video
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye